may god lead your friend to light pastor
you're my boss you tell me who the hell
is two more two more two more okay
all right i have to say two more all
right and the case is closed yes
uh
two questions
[Laughter]
okay professor uh
yes number one
it's competitive sports yes
acknowledged by god
is what
is it acknowledged by god acknowledged
yes okay okay
and the other question is
improperly doing communion partaking of
communion right
food washing is necessary
because of the situation we're in now
should we feel that as a people of god
should we do one fear
for washing as a people of god
okay all right so those are the
questions okay all right
let me get to them one competitive
sports
they are not of god the contrary to the
spirit of christ christ's spirit is i
lose so you can win that's calvary
i lose
for your sakes he became poor that ye
through his poverty might become rich
competitive sports says i will do
everything i can to stop you from
scoring one goal
i will slam you to the boards in ice
hockey i will break your legs in
football i will look undercut you in
basketball i will whatever competitive
sports are not of god
i'm upsetting those of you who worship
arsenal manchester united competitive
sports are not of god this is the
houston astros or whatever they are not
of god are you with me recreation is of
god
difference i remember many years ago i
was in the house of a friend of mine and
he had a table tennis in the basement so
he and i were just hitting the ball
he said let's play a game i said why
come on let's play why let's hit the
ball come on let's play a game so we
played i beat him 21-5
that was the end of his desire to play a
game he wanted someone to win or lose
this is not the spirit of god
you see it on pick up games on the
playgrounds someone fouled no i didn't
foul you foul they look like a foul you
fouled it
no not me they put their hands up lying
lying
competitive sports are not of god what
was the other one